far cry 6 has taken over my life
recently and i absolutely love it so
much so that i've compiled all the
secrets i've found and those found by
the community and put them into one
video and this is that video we've got
ghosts we've got street fighter 2
characters as chickens we've got a way
to link all the far cry games together
so sit your butt down for 15 minutes and
enjoy 40 secrets and easter eggs found
in far cry 6.
[Music]
on the starting island one of the first
easter eggs you will find is here at
this suspicious looking tower if you're
getting assassin's creed vibes you're
already onto something scale this
building and you'll see a wooden board
and should you walk to the end a very
familiar sound can be heard
the eagles cry to signal a leap of faith
in assassin's creed games and sure
enough on the ground below is a haystack
to jump into like you've seen hundreds
of assassins do before you
jumping down though will result in your
death assassin's creed has taught us to
not question things like this
but wait around at an npc should bring
you back to life hopefully if you are
more into scary easter eggs be sure to
visit the cemetery in konucho you'll
find this building and inside is a note
which talks about a ghost in the
vicinity
turn around at the right time and you'll
see a blue glow quickly vanish
to get the full easter egg you need to
come back here at night
[Music]
[Applause]
this time when you read it the ghost
will be waiting behind you and directs
the player to a nearby grave here is
another note which talks about the death
of a young soldier which caused this man
and his wife to separate scary and sad
all in one i thought this was the end of
the easter egg but no it continues by
simply traveling to the place mentioned
in the final note casadario you'll find
this
[Applause]
yeah it's a tomb of the wife who was
slain by the husband because he was
jealous that she was moving on from her
grief about their son's death wow that
was darker than i expected let's crack
on
[Music]
a happier easter egg can be found at
multiple locations on the map thanks to
a dynamic system they have where events
change randomly for example up in the
right hand corner of the map escaped
captives will free each other from their
shackles then by returning later they
have collected items to build a raft and
finally a little later on you'll visit
again the final survivor completes that
escape raft and this also looks like a
castaway movie easter egg he even has a
ball to keep him company the new wilson
another example sees this guy happily
using a gas canister to add a little
more heat to his cooking but if you keep
coming back here this will happen
hot stuff the dynamic events continue
and thanks to reddit a spot was quickly
found which rotates through many random
events which is just here on the map
each time you visit the event will
change it could be an arrest it could be
a dead horse it could be two guardians
digging a grave for a fallen soldier or
it could be one of these two the first
is something i cannot explain a canister
of poison with a ring of flamingos and
fish around it and i honestly have no
idea what this means if you could help
me out please do so i'll be in the
comments trying to figure out what this
is however there is a 1 in 20 chance you
will face this a bucket in the sand
seems legit right well shoot off that
bucket to reveal a human buried up to
his neck this looks to be an easter egg
to the same event in far cry 3. that was
called welcome to the internet which was
yet another easter egg referencing the
advertisement for far cry 3 in which
vast buried mcluvin and tortured him
that became such a big part of the
attention around the game that vass and
the buried man were on the front cover
of the final game but wait this is not
the end we can add a third easter egg to
this using photo mode it's possible to
pose dany in many different ways and one
of those happens to be vas a near
identical pose with twin handguns
allowing us to recreate the front cover
of far cry 3 in far cry 6. this whole
thing is like easter egg inception but
damn it was good fyi there are other
poses and references to other games and
movies whilst in photo mode we have the
iconic marvel superhero pose after
landing on one knee
superhero landing for some reason we
have the pose from the movie platoon
i guess it fits it's a war movie about
jungle warfare and guria tactics we have
the assassins creed jumping pose when
the assassins about to strike their prey
there's a pose from the father in far
cry 5 and this one does anyone remember
this one it's a viral video from long
ago a man would approach women on the
beach and do a backflip and set into
this pose to start a conversation that
guy is smooth
there's a ubisoft easter egg treasure
trove to be found sadly it isn't a
literal treasure trove it's notes and
let's be honest who actually reads notes
in video games during the cash money
treasure hunt you'll be taken to this
airfield inside the bunker is a few
references to other games this note has
four items listed on them let's start
from the bottom and work upwards a pair
of ancient concealed blades that can be
extended and retracted from a gauntlet
incredible
yes it is this must be the hidden blade
from the assassin's creed series above
that is a simple urn which is most
likely that of aj's mother in far cry 4.
next up is a knife of chinese origin
featuring a silver dragon icon i'm
guessing this is the knife from far cry
3 and finally an ancient spear once
broken repaired multiple times i thought
this was a far cry primal reference but
the word on the street is this is the
ancient spear of leonidas in the
assassin's creed series
but wait there's one more easter egg in
this room over by the shelves is a note
describing a forgotten ubisoft game
starlink battle for atlas a space-themed
adventure game from 2018 and to confirm
this there is one of the models right
next to it on the shelf i've got to
admit i've never played starlink have
you and speaking of ubisoft games and in
particular far cry games since far cry 4
we've always had a shortcut way to end
the game in 4 we could simply sit at the
table for 15 minutes and be recruited by
the man we were sent to overthrow in far
cry 5 we could simply refuse to arrest
the father walking away and now in far
cry 6 we can simply sail away grab a
boat and leave the map however you
choose the moment most of us figured
this out is after the first set piece
mission where dany shows that she's not
really into this rebellion lark and is
given a boat to sail away and then we
receive this secret ending
in other news war has ended in europe
president anton castillo announced that
clara garcia the leader of the terrorist
group libertad was killed by his special
forces
and as the pandemic tightens its grip on
the globe the federal government may
impose another nationwide lockdown
but first how about something a little
more upbeat
[Music]
not the greatest ending but at least
danny got to the states like she always
wanted and yeah my danny is a girl deal
with it
there is a double easter egg to find in
the town of concepcion a treasure hunt
will have you locate the emerald skull
something clearly based on the crystal
skull indiana jones movie you can
actually find indy's body along the way
sorry bro once we find the emerald skull
a booby trap sets off just like in the
movies and we have to jump for our lives
but in addition to this read the notes
around the area and you'll find them
from a guy with a very similar name to
alan quartermaine the hero of the 1885
novel by h rider haggard about king
solomon's mind indiana jones was heavily
inspired by that novel
so have you tried the game within a game
the chicken brawler i'm not going to use
its real name because youtube doesn't
like it so i'm going to stay clear well
did you know that there is some free dlc
in the ubisoft store you can grab right
now sets of roosters for all but some of
these are very familiar to gamers like
me and you there is a pair named frosty
and toasty styled to look like scorpion
and sub-zero from mortal kombat the
small print on toasty references
scorpion's iconic get over here move
this time called inviting his foes
closer
oh and the name toasty is also an easter
egg to an easter egg in mortal combat
street fighter have a pair of battling
male chickens too the dragon and his
rival are intended to look like ryu and
ken in that iconic series the fighting
arena is heavily based on tekken so i'm
expecting some of those fighters to be
added soon let's keep an eye on that
store and that free dlc
here's an easter egg i haven't verified
but i really hope it's true at various
points around the island there are hubs
which give off this morse code sound it
turns out someone went to the trouble to
decode them and some of them read
cameron britain is the greatest sound
designer of all time and guess who
cameron britain is none other than
ubisoft's lead sound designer there are
other nods to the development team of
far cry 6 around the world there's a
shout out to a group of developers if
you get your butt over to a place called
maria masqueza productions sorry for
that terrible pronunciation there is a
trailer here with a purple line across
it and a note sitting on the desk which
thanks those developers gg devs do you
remember when qr codes came out and they
were everywhere in video games we had to
get out our phones in real life and scan
the screens well far cry 6 has brought
them back scanning codes in the game
with your phone will lead to a few
strange places
these shipping crates will send you to a
short animation which looks to be
teasing the dlc for the game coming soon
and was that an armored battle cat
another scannable code is found on the
blood dragon pet you may have with your
copy of the game yeah the code is around
his neck grab your phone and scan this
to be taken to a site from dolph laser
hawk fresh out of far cry blood dragon
this will then lead you to a puzzle to
be solved which then leads you to a
teaser for the upcoming netflix show
about captain laser hawk very meta
before we move on to the last big easter
eggs a few things the community has
noticed there is a full metal jacket
weapon charm the small print reads what
is your major malfunction a line
straight from the movie of the same name
which is another movie about guerrilla
warfare what is your major malfunction
numbnuts if you kill a shark with a
grenade you'll unlock the trophy jawsome
in honor of the jaws movie and how
they've dispatched a much bigger shark
with an explosion this trophy is
actually another double easter egg with
a play on words about jason brodie the
main protagonist in far cry
and remember when that was revealed one
of the first things we saw jason do was
punch a shark in the head jason brodie
is awesome he's jawsome
another trophy is named at can you pet
the croc after meeting your first amigo
this is a nod to the twitter account can
you pet the dog which chronicles all the
animals mainly dogs that can be
interacted with in video games
there's a couple of breaking bad
references in far cry 6. the first is
actually a nod to another evil character
played by giancarlo esposito go spring
take a listen to this line from gus
a dog
who bites
every owner he's had
can only be disciplined with a firm hand
or
put down and now move a few words around
and listen to anton pretty much say the
same thing and
if a dog
refuses to break
like
julio here
then we
must put them down
it's like they are the same character
they even look and sound a bit similar
too a second breaking bad easter egg is
out in the world on another note on a
refrigerator at a basket farm you can
read about a bald meth dealer from
american tv i don't know many of them so
it has to be walter white right
[Music]
now let's go through a series of easter
eggs and secrets that link all the far
cry games into one chronology we already
know the timelines are converging thanks
to the dlc coming to the game soon i'm
sure you've spotted the video game
system ready to unlock this feature in
the future with images of joseph seed
vass and pagan min just waiting to be
unlocked during your time in yara you'll
encounter lorenzo an old gorilla who has
fathered a few children shall we say in
one side mission we hunt down seven of
his illegitimate children it's it's it's
just weird okay two of them were
accidentally in a relationship together
which is really gross the more you think
about it anyway one of those kids can
only be found after sniffing this plant
a bliss flower from far cry 5 which
causes hallucinations and just like in
far cry 5 the person we're trying to get
to teleports away leaving this green
glow behind
welcome to the bliss
and it must be said both women wear a
very similar dress and acts in a very
similar way and then have a listen to
what they say it's from lorenzo canseco
the father
your real father despite all that you
have done you are not beyond salvation
you are not here by accident or by
chance
thank you for this letter uh you are
welcome everything is unfolding
according to god's plan
i am still here with you the first seal
has been broken okay
i'm out the father the seals it's all
from far cry 5. so that links lorenzo
via his daughter to that of joseph seed
and far cry 5. and should you go back to
lorenzo's house he has a copy of a
magazine and look who's upon it none
other than pagan min he's still alive i
don't know how because he definitely
died in far cry 4 but hey let's see how
they get around this another far cry 5
reference can be found through a side
mission for juan will be sent to find a
shipping container filled with american
weapons yet when we get there we find
this
how did you get in here boy
he looks a great deal like boomer from
far cry 5 and dany even gives him a new
name give it a name
okay how about
uh boom boom perfect boom boom probably
changed as the word boomer kinda means
something different these days boom boom
is acceptable i guess it turns out that
juan is very much aware of the other
walls around the world take a listen to
his opening words in the game today we
drink in the worst cantina in yara
straight out of far cry 4. and should
you visit his headquarters later in the
game you'll receive this dog tag and
look who it belongs to willis huntley an
american cia agent who's more like an
arms dealer and smuggler to be honest
who appears in far cry 3 4 and 5. so
these two characters know each other i
don't want to go into spoiler territory
so i'll not explain this one very well
just like all the others later in the
game there is an option to speak to
mckay it may be tough not to shoot him
on site but if you resist he'll
monologue about his ventures this
includes talking on a satellite phone to
willis confirming he's still alive i'm
happy you're late willis it makes me
look good so and stick around even
longer and mckay will call longinus from
far cry 4.
longinus baby come on where have you
been who if i remember rightly sent us
to find a blood diamond this could all
be fan service but it certainly feels
like far cry is indeed one single
timeline but the biggest easter egg and
reference to the far cry world being one
instance is heard after the game ends
stick around after the credits to hear
this
thanks you for your support
and i come bearing good news
our riviera supply has tripled
ah
you know he's so sad about that castillo
kid i mean what is papatite
wow
that is crazy
man
a tragedy
well you know some people are just
seeking the mind that man
they're out of control
same time next week
well you can bet your life on it
it's pretty clear that juan is speaking
to vas
this could be some time travel bs or
maybe all the villains we thought died
in their games are actually still alive
which makes me really keen to play the
new dlc which means i have to pay more
money okay that's quite clever ubisoft
ggs so there we have it ladies and gents
40 secrets easter eggs and references to
other pieces of media i hope you enjoyed
let me know if i missed anything i'll
see you soon